what's up guys bang-bang lunch money
time while Wall Street's trying to get
rich the rest of us just trying to get a
lunch money right I am here with the
beautiful plenum Air Nova she obviously
has a hat on what how do you have this
happen because je on YouTube said that
he would unsubscribe from this channel
if I didn't wear a hat so I wore a hot J
are you going to battle for the
subscribers in the comments or this one
subscribe if he subscribes all of you so
none all right well now that I'm sitting
here like Beyonce you know in that one
in like a lemonade where she's like this
I was like middle fingers up no now that
I have farmer Polina here what's going
on Lebanon yeah we have to do the show
like you can't just say it's not fashion
show it's an actual show routine so in
Lebanon there's economic protests that
are turning violent and a man has died
following overnight clashes between
protesters and soldiers yeah so big news
here is for the number of months leading
into kovat 19 crisis there was a lot of
anti-government protests by people in
the streets and then Kobe 19 came
everyone went inside and pretty much
abided by the stay-at-home order but in
the last week or so they started to let
people out they've reduced some of the
curfew they've also opened some
businesses but simultaneously the
Lebanese Pound has dropped 50% and is
now trading at some of the lowest levels
against US dollars ever trade that so
can you explain how that's possible
while the US dollar is getting stronger
even though we're still under lockdown
so exactly think of it as a fraction if
you go back to school
there's the Lebanese pound and the
dollar and when one gets stronger the
other gets weaker right so the dollar is
strengthening and the pound is going
down and shot 50% which means if you're
sitting there let's say that you get
paid a hundred Lebanese pounds for the
right or for the month all the sudden
that 100 Lebanese pound you're still
getting paid the same amount but when
you go to the store that loaf of bread
that used to cost them I get 5 to 5
pounds now cost 20 pounds so they're
eating into your actual income you're
actually getting paid the less money cuz
all the goods are going up right the
food prices are skyrocketing and second
of all imagine if you had saved a
hundred pounds right Lebanese pounds
dint used to be able to buy 20 loaves of
bread right five for $100 100 pounds now
all of a sudden if food has gone up to
20 pounds per loaf now you can't leave
buy five of them so your wealth is
actually being stolen from you as well
what would need to happen in the US for
that to happen here well they continue
to devalue the currency so what
literally what these people are going
into the street and protesting is that
gone they started to attack banks
because they're saying hey and the
central bank so they're saying at the
banks they're saying I want my money
back I realize that you're devaluing my
currency I'm losing wealth you're
stealing my well for me give me my money
back but the banks have withdrawal
limits they say you can only withdraw a
certain amount of money every day so
they literally won't give you your money
back
and then on top of that they used to
allow people in Lebanon to withdraw and
certain currencies so if you go to the
thing today you could have gotten US
dollars Lebanese pound whatever now they
will only let you withdraw it and
Lebanese pounds and so people are
literally watching their wealth get
stolen from them
so when they do they go in the street
and they start attacking to get their
money back they set up Bank on fire
yes and they've also got up to the
central bank and it's just a really
really bad situation so lots of social
unrest we're nowhere near that the
United States today well why is the US
dollar soaring I don't understand it's
called deflation so in a deflationary
environment what basically happens is
all of the asset prices sell off
everything goes oh you are going down
this rabbit hole this is exactly what
everyone's learning about right now so
in a deflationary environment
everyone gets very nervous right they
say I don't want all these other assets
I want dollars because dollars equals
stability safety all of this stuff so in
a deflationary environment everyone runs
$4 and they look around their portfolio
and they sell whatever they have so I'll
so my goal of my stocks whatever and I
want dollars the dollar strengthens all
the assets so
the government realizes this and says
hey we've got to provide the social
safety net to citizens and also at some
point we're gonna have to systematically
weaken the dollar to stabilize markets
and to eventually have them recover so
they started printing a bunch of money
right right now what's happening is it's
such a deflationary environment in the
US economy that no matter how much they
print is just getting eaten up by that
deflationary environment so it's not
enough to switch back to the inflation
and also relatively imagine if the US
dollar relatively yeah it's like
comparing two things is that a work it's
relative relative to okay with the
English major who didn't major in
English there are relative to other
economies even though the US is printing
trillions other economies are printing
lots of money as well and so in this
example the US dollar is strengthening
and the Lebanese pounds going down so
people at Lebanon are getting screwed
they're out in the streets they're
literally protesting they're sending
banks on fire they're fighting back
because they don't understand what's
going on and the best way to think about
this is in my opinion this isn't an
anti-government movement this is a pro
general population movement these are
people saying we deserve to live in
freedom we deserve to live in a place
where when I wake up I don't worry about
my wealth being stolen from me and I
don't worry about having or not having
enough money to go buy groceries we're
lucky to be here very lucky all right
speaking of so could you just get an
economics class like all in three
minutes and I think I sold out at one
point then I saw back in okay so a bunch
of states are starting to reopen
including Georgia Alaska and Texas
shocker at all oh sorry alright so
states are reopening do you think is a
good idea or not so Alaska I feel like
they're pretty socially distant
Texas same George I think Texas is
socially distant I think that well
they're not they're not just saying like
free-for-all like we're just opening
everything they're doing it in phases so
like if you're a restaurant
only operate it like 30 percent or
whatever so basically they're trying
you're trying to put it in still social
distancing while opening yes and I just
don't know how I feel about it because
obviously there's a lot of different
sides tear and Chrome virus is still
infecting people but at some point so
like there's this Barbara here who in
this article and he goes if I don't cut
I don't eat so he literally cannot you
know survive if he doesn't have this
business I think it's important to at
least have a plan to reopen and I guess
this is phase one for a lot of these
things I think that they should reopen
immediately look everyone what they
should do is they should Rio they should
say if you're an entrepreneur small
business owner go open your place if you
want to open your restaurant your
business whatever you're happier so able
to do that we are no longer gonna stop
you from it if you are a consumer and
you want to go in that business you're
allowed to do that but as a business
owner we are going to require that you
put in place things to ensure social
distancing attention just like in New
York when you walk into CBS or Duane
Reade they have little marks on the
ground when you stand in line and things
like that why not allow all of the other
entrepreneurs and small businesses to
have access to revenue as long as they
follow some set of social distancing
rules well I just I think it's tough
right like there's there's a number of
businesses where you can't really
enforce social distancing like let's say
like a nail salon like I think it's your
gonna be touching what you wear the hat
we're talking about nail salons you're
touching hands you're putting your hand
in the water it's just but but the whole
point is if you're worried about getting
sick don't go to the nail salon if
you're worried about doing I'm not
worried about getting sick and that's
the problem because they then go infect
elderly people there oh but but again it
we should shelter the old the sick those
with pre-existing conditions we should
everything we can to protect them but
because we're protecting them shouldn't
stop you me or anybody else from going
to do things we want to do but now
here's that here's a
wild idea people navigate personal
responsibility if you get sick it's
going to because the things you did know
the majority of the population doesn't
think that individualistically and
they're not in their interests visions
basically do what they're told and I
think they're sheep basically but you
have to prevent people from themselves a
lot of times you keep you bet but that's
not the role of government the
government is not to protect you from
yourself
that's that's why I see both sides all
right that's fair speaking of
restaurants when they reopen these
they're actually gonna do it in many
cases I think like 25 kappa % opacity
50% capacity sad and lonely is that
forget sad and lonely the businesses
aren't gonna be able to they're
literally gonna be underwater so if I'm
a restaurant open up with 25% capacity I
might as well not be alive right because
now I've got expenses that I didn't have
when I was closed and I've got I'm
losing revenue and every customer that
comes through so it's actually
accelerating losses it's so stupid but
by the way the virus is real they should
take measures to take care of people
prevent the spread do all these things
but it doesn't again I've been saying
from day one it does not happy a black
and white either we saved the health
crisis or we saved the economic crisis
we can address both at the same time as
you see in New York for example the
latest antibody testing shows that 20
over 20% close to 25% of people that
they tested in New York in a random
sample has now proven to have grown a
virus which means has had way more
people have it or have been infected
than they originally thought and that
also means that the death rate is way
lower than they originally thought
newsflash
just like a bunch of people have been
saying until you have proper testing you
can't make good decisions I'm on the
record as saying by the time this is all
over when we have all the data they're
gonna look back and say we made a
mistake by shutting down the economy and
sending everyone home I think their egos
are way too big to ever say they'll
never say it but it'll just be so
obvious it'll say look at the end of the
day here's the actual stats now again
give you the information we had at the
time you have to overreact right if
you're gonna miss if you under react and
millions could die or you overreact and
then it ends up not being as bad as you
thought then you obviously want to
overreact
the difference though is the next time
that this happens sorry bargain listen
my question is like as these countries
in Europe start to open and some of the
states start to open I mean there's a
lot of business being done between
States between countries how are you
going to say these companies can now or
these types of businesses can now open
these businesses cannot and I'll over
here saying like well I need to do
business with that company but they're
not a central so it's just like very
hard to delineate this is why people are
already in the streets there are already
protests around this country saying you
as the government cannot tell me whether
I can open my business or not happen you
as the government or playing kingmaker
you're choosing polina's business can be
open but Anthony's can how do they get
to choose that where is their
constitutional power to do that that is
the point of the Constitution is to
protect us from a government that
overreaches and right now there
overreach so all this to say speaking of
businesses and the government loan
audits what's going on here so the
government it's gonna audit any company
that took out more than two million
dollars from the small business loan
program so what does that mean so if I
took they basically want to make sure
that I'm paying my people in doing
everything in the provisions I think
there's two pieces to this so if you
applied and receive more than two
million dollars they're now gonna come
behind it audit and they're gonna say
did you actually need the long it's were
you affected by cope it or did you just
apply and take money that somebody else
could have gotten and to did you use it
for the intended purposes were they you
could argue that favor why everybody was
affected what's the profile affected no
right but that's why you didn't apply
right so that businesses that were
affected they're gonna get audited and
they're not the fruit where we actually
affected you don't want me okay we would
have so many hats we'd have to get a new
apartment but this is important because
now all of its coming out there 200 plus
public companies applied for it there's
people who are say that I could give the
money back and the audit my guess is
that the audit is gonna take a long time
is gonna be super expensive this is
classic government bureaucracy right
rather than do the work upfront we're
give the money to a bunch of people and
then go behind it on this create more
bureaucracy but to is this is actually
probably a fear tactic they're simply
trying to scare people into saying if
you don't deserve the money if you don't
actually qualify the threat of the audit
will prevent you from upon right that's
my guess
so speaking of businesses next topic
Shopify what's going on there Shopify
has a new app called shop Wow very
creative how did they get the treatment
okay well named Shopify you can do
whatever but it's an app and people
really like it tell us about it Anthony
cuz you seem passionate about it this
mean that you didn't read it no all
right I just Shopify is doing a
fantastic job I think of one providing a
path for income for a lot of people so
there's people who previously would have
not had ecommerce store set up but
Shopify over the years have built an
incredible tool set to allow people to
go on very quickly set up an online
store and during something like
quarantine where everyone's busy retail
businesses or storefronts are shut down
the ability to sell online is obviously
a lifeline for a lot of these businesses
so I think that's one cool too is
they're releasing this new app and a lot
of people I don't think know that they
have all these other products so like
they've got this shop after lets you
track packages similar to how you can
track your amazon packages they've got
something called Shopify money actually
and Alex Danko who used to be a social
capital and does a lot of writing on the
Internet he recently just joined and
it's all about how do they provide
financial services to their small
business owners and so I think Shopify
is just one of those companies that we
all know about it but like in a time
like this it's very obvious what a good
job they're doing to help people
actually get income because literally
they can't go get it in their
storefronts so we have these friends and
every time we're hanging out with them
you hear they're so they have a company
where they sell physical product and you
hear their phones OH Ching can we say
yeah it's a if you go to where Adams
comm I think it is Adams the shoe it's
the most comfortable shoes ever I have
them over there I wear
earlier on an ad he's been wearing them
for a year now I literally wear them
every single day that the only shoes
that I wear and our friends will cost in
Sitra came from Pakistan and they
created the shoe company raised a bunch
of money have absolutely killed it and
when we're hanging out they have the
notifications on and literally every
time they get a sale it's it's like that
little thing we're talking you sure all
right what's going on with the alien
world
you look like an alien with this hat on
I do feel a little like you know super
serious topics with this do you and I
know I was living with a fashion
influencer I bought this hat on the
street in New York City congratulations
that's amazing great job Polina what's
going on billions the Pentagon
officially released these videos of
these UFOs flying through the air and I
thought I really thought that I had seen
this before you have oh these videos so
I didn't realize this but these videos
hit were all leaked back like 2050 total
six know they were leaked and they were
on the internet and nobody knew like for
sure if they were real or not but it was
pretty well confirmed like these were
leaked from a legitimate service then
the Pentagon finally now of all times
from the middle of Kovan 19 the North
Korean dictator possibly being dead all
these crazy things going on in the world
like oh yeah we're gonna officially
release those videos that you guys have
been looking at for years there were
unidentified aerial phenomena is what
they actually call them not UFOs but
they happen basically confirmed that
these videos are real they're all
authentic and they were taken by us I
think like Air Forces Navy pilots and
now they're out the public confirmed I
personally I don't care that much about
the video what I like is like the
narrator or like the person seeing it
and I watched one of the videos and he's
like oh my god it's like flying against
the wind so fast
well it's science like that that's why
that's why as you dig into some of the
critical conspiracy theories around
alien
or UFOs and also these people will say
thing
a piece of machinery that can do what
that thing just did you know it'll it'll
go like there's one where it's busy
flying and then out of nowhere it'll
just explode vertical right and Bieber
said we just don't have a piece of
machinery that can do that so how do you
explain it
identify that's really weird but you
know what I'm apparently one of the
people speculated that a computer oh I
mean could that be a possibility it
could be but that's what they're trying
to figure out unidentified by the way
why is the topic aliens if we're talking
about UFOs
because UFOs don't necessarily have to
be connected because this is new why do
you want to regulate
I'm just curious so like okay so let's
say this these were aliens why wouldn't
they try to get in contact with us well
that's what people want to know is has
the u.s. ever come in contact with
aliens Thompson no yeah okay come on
just just imagine if you answered Trump
said no if he was briefed on all this
stuff and aliens was one of the things
you don't think he'd come out and be
like guys I'm a tweet real fast no I
don't think that that any president
would do that because it would again I
know you have to remember that
presidents understand the control of the
population is so important like you
don't want people to imagine if tomorrow
they were like hey we've talked to the
aliens and they're on this I know all
right what else anything else oh so are
you ready for what so what is an alien
where you tell me a riddle it's a joke
oh well you have 24 seconds make it a
good what do a lien z' wear to weddings
what do a Lian's wear to weddings I have
no clue spacesuits
it's bad really are you really bringing
out bad jokes okay how do you like
parent aliens get their baby aliens to
go to sleep
drugged them they rock it like like
rocket that's not funny why you bombed
that one literally mom all right you're
1 for 2 on the jokes I appreciate the
alien jokes people I appreciate you
watching through this tumultuous time
I've got a fashion icon here with me now
do you want to promote whose hat that is
you don't need only a street vendor
I think it's Angela and William actually
is what the tag says but what do I know
I'm not necessarily the most fashionable
office I do appreciate you wearing a
black t-shirt today thanks putting the
uniform on while she's trying to get
rich the rest of us just trying to get a
lunch money right we appreciate you guys
watching this show we will keep trying
to bring it to you right around noon
we're getting better
thank you for co-hosting right before we
started recording planet called me an
idiot that means that we had a great
show so and that is it for lunch money
today
bang bang see you guys tomorrow